[Music]
three two one action all right welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want and it's over the
rainbow give me wrong information
already right oh yeah how you have you
been been good all things considered
yeah I feel kind of guilty this year cuz
like it sucks for everybody I think
isn't for you yes off to a great start
and then when this all happened it was
kind of like well it's not so great but
things are still going well and like I
don't you know
knock on wood but I feel like this is
the first year for all of humanity that
just kind of across the board sucks what
was going so well for you is this cuz
you have online business business online
businesses yeah so it was just like the
last couple years it was kind of spent
fixing some things that weren't really
going well and putting new things in
place that were finally starting to work
it's like 20/20 my year let's go off to
a good start did some traveling right
when I got back from New Orleans for a
friend's bachelor party in uh into
February it was like quarantine this is
weird
and then it's like every month something
crazy and you're just like all right
things are still going well for me and I
feel like this is all right but you know
you still have this anxiety of like
where's the world going like when's it
not gonna go well for me
where's kind of weird I kind of thrive
in chaos yeah are you thriving right now
[Laughter]
I'm laughing my way to the bank because
of all the people there like this is a
[ __ ] risky career choice you're
making
whose took who took the risk now
[ __ ] but all the people that are
actually going through some [ __ ] I'm
sorry you never did anything wrong I'm
just talking to my people close to me
not you get the five people that [ __ ]
you know five or more they're actually
very supportive yeah I don't really know
a lot of people I don't know
I made it up just to give yourself like
motivation right I have an enemy that I
probably created my family's actually
very supportive and they never judged me
for this
this was 2010 it would have been my dad
so my dad like like he judged me hard
for doing YouTube and he would have been
can he was a car dealer yeah
so casinos are all shut down so if this
happened in 2010 haha jobless
[ __ ] in your baby but now I
gotta support is us who's got the stable
job now yeah pass dad that wasn't
approving of you yeah we haven't really
been hit that hard huh like in terms of
like our job security and you can't do
[ __ ] we just can't go out I feel super
fortunate no I I feel extremely bad
mainly for our restaurant staff because
they got no right no now we are so it's
not pasta that's one of the things I was
concerned about because I was like oh
thank god we still can pay our staff in
JK thanks to you guys too for the
patreon support and all that stuff and
you know it's it's I think that it sucks
because every time there's a shift in
the world like a pandemic or like a war
or like something happens right it's
almost like certain people will win and
certain people won't like it it always
it always goes down that way and then
sometimes a lot of businesses are
created during a depression or recession
so when some people are suffering
there's almost like a weird balance
shift that's happening where like you
know some people are using that
opportunity or that this this downtime
as an opportunity to create something
new yeah we know that's like almost like
I mean it sucks to say but that's almost
like the theory of evolution and natural
selection but just in human form yeah I
guess the concept of it is you have two
giraffes right one with the short ass
neck and the one with the long ass neck
and then when the trees all of them get
all tall the short neck giraffes there
like [ __ ] where's my food and they just
end up dying and the tall asked ones
that could barely like balance
themselves in the wind I think is eating
[ __ ] good the tall giraffe the toddler
Avenue [ __ ] [ __ ] I understand listen
orange and give it to the little guy say
you got two giraffes are an evolution in
man big wobbly one short guy looks look
look visibly looks better than the tall
one but it's the one yeah yeah he's
gonna win we don't see short-necked raza
that would be tight if we could actually
ride dressed
I played out I wanna I guess like the
back are like like you put on a tree
when you're hunting like one of those
things you put I just see this I thought
that'd be the best but not all so it'd
be them the shakiest yeah yeah I think
during this time though it's like if you
had all this down time it would've been
cool to try to like push for something
that you want to do that you never could
like for everyone that kind of like is
this effective pretty much everyone yeah
and there's stuff people that like like
we gonna still make videos and stuff but
there's a lot of people just had nothing
to do I feel like if you took the time
properly after you kinda like got over
like the fear and stuff I pick up a
hobby or pick up a han Solo anyway
anyone do that here
yeah yeah no I was gonna say I was like
yeah I was gonna ask the theme if he
picked one of things you always wanted
to do like but it's like we could have
drinking cooking a few other things
we're supposed to do our movie every
failed sir we did fail Oh
you're here and this that we do he's
here
why don't you make him do it oh yes yes
you'll do it at the end cuz he asked the
host all day yeah I think they did such
a good friend that he's gonna do it
again I didn't do it again with everyone
up what am I talking about
so there was a pact between a dame Tim
and Casey about having a movie yet
finish in two weeks because they've been
wanting to do movie since I think last
year but things just keep happening in a
dog all right finally
no excuses we're gonna have a pact to
finish after two weeks of being the DM
wrote like 10 or 15 pages hero like ten
nine or ten pages Tim I don't have a 2-0
but it wasn't the whole movies we should
we should have had had a read it and
said whoever finished the most least
amount of pages pages gets the
punishment oh I was thinking it should
be like a like a drop per certain amount
of pages you didn't finish
I don't know they could have done more
than one drop Tim did you did we yeah
Barbra gate was like a five drop it was
not five drops as though more than one
drop will [ __ ] you up though it was like
two or three drops it's the one it's
called Satan's blood oh it's not
flashbang and I couldn't drive maybe ten
pages you don't finish you know average
120 pages you did like 15 pages kind of
movie you write you should have seen he
threw up and meet you he was out for
like three videos how do how do we know
if it says strongest flash manga I don't
know I don't know but Nadine was just
constantly throwing up and they look bad
the school bills on that 800,000 what's
the flash bang I think that flash plane
is two million but they go by a
different unit ID they go by don't
discover they go by rupees MC you Marvel
Cinematic Universe but it was like an SI
unit wait so there's like a metric and
English system for skull hills to like a
inches and centimeters to begin with
I feel like I shouldn't really hot man
giant numbers more chilies more chili
when you measure by green Chili's or red
cheese it's like where did it start do
you think do it start it like ten no
like this isn't this is way hotter
two million yeah eating that was that
ten with that many or they start really
low and everything just got hotter and
hotter maybe big red is tend to go cuz
everything's got to start I'm really the
minute you have a pepper it's got to be
like already a thousand how do you feel
about somebody who pulls out big red
like that sir come a choice that's weird
like it but it's definitely not gonna be
the gum like packet yeah but if
someone's like you're gonna get a stick
of gum like yes sure big red really I've
seen that [ __ ] in like ten years
how about [ __ ] time capsule you crawl
oh that's funny yeah it's like this is a
small pack [ __ ] pump your brakes does
it go
those are good place I would never
expect yeah you didn't crop with the
[ __ ] Mexican Thea alright no I what
do they do have a bunch in their purse
[ __ ] yeah we do if it comes out of a
purse but you eat all five at one
sitting and the mint [ __ ] no yeah no
you're supposed to put the whole thing
in your mouth yeah that's really MIT
yeah you take one little little
rectangle and doesn't it make a breath
smell worse because it's real sugar
probably it just rots your teeth
so after it feeds the bacteria that's in
their mouth already it's funny that they
call like people I get like the really
bad veneers the chiclet teeth yeah looks
like it looks like that's a lot
wait what the Denzel what's-his-name
factor there's a Washington yeah his
teeth look like perfect yeah because
he's got the before they'd be paroled
veneers oh yeah I never notice it I
don't think it's so perfect
well never they're perfect I'm talking
about the one that just looked big and
not perfect get a ninja turtle yeah
guys out that person they have the
biggest you like you go in you're like
give me that book my flight to go get
that I don't like it you're doing it
yeah yeah you booked it I booked
everything you know and then to Turkey
right Turkey but you can do everything
you want right so they have like a
computer system to do it x-ray but then
once they show you how they want to fix
your teeth then I hate this is what it
looks normal and natural right and it's
all but there's a thirty different
colors of teeth you choose and they're
like nobody listens to us because it's
your complete choice but this is what
looks natural always go for the the hall
even wider one they go for the Hollywood
white and they go where your teeth are
just like like that like that editorial
where it's looks like it looks like just
easier for them to make right it's just
one piece and they just I wish to double
if we can floss anymore evolutions got
two teeth that will save so much time do
they kinda want that yeah
wait so do you have to get any teeth
removed so they from for mine it's a its
crowns yeah they're doing is here's like
my tooth right and they shave off layers
of it and then they put a cap on top so
let's say you take the vineyard so it's
a lot it's a permanent yeah it's
permanent
oh do a gold one that's like I kind of
want to go to they'd all have a goal to
but they have a really really yellow one
cuz I get why I'm not a gold engine
viable so I think why would even offer
that as an option like you want copied
you know sometimes you get one right and
then they have to match your on the rest
of it so yeah yeah match the copy - yeah
they should just upsell be like well
whiten your teeth is a white in the
yellow one no it doesn't it doesn't
change it's a different tint yeah so
that's why the people that get the pure
wise cuz they're like what is they just
pure pure white yeah but it's like you'd
never have to do anything about them
like if you got the wash your teeth do a
lot of things your white leg looks
almost
range is just yellow that's why yeah
it's like so they recommended a third of
for shade so if you get your super
Hollywood white do you gotta get your
tongue bleach to LA cuz now your tongues
gonna pop out it's all it's too rich but
you look at what your tongue shoe that
would look like you're sick what do you
know wait McCall
purple now that's drip bro wait eat this
yeah so what goes in succession where
it's like the stuff enters and comes out
so you got to make sure everything's
perfectly clean I've thought about
except just because recently I they do
it in Turkey wait you caught a glimpse
yeah catch a glimpse can I have a mirror
like a huge my own your butt cheeks have
to be open were you taking a photo of
your style with the bone in your toes
I've been over did you look I forgot why
but I was like okay I just wanna look
I'm over I never want to bob was like
okay that color does not match the rest
of my body what color was it
it was to match the same I wanted to cuz
like what do you see a girl isn't it so
nice doesn't it match your ballsack
that's a oh no I'm gonna assume your
bottle is like purple my brother's like
red no that's what it look like it would
be baboon but that gets like super and
throw the ringer power they'll melt the
initial [ __ ] walls I in jail then it
turns black because the hair but why do
you want to make sure than the crime you
want to make a nice presentation if you
don't do ass play or do you now it's
polite what the [ __ ] play is it polite
yes when I lit it would just be groomed
all over
the food is different I want the wine if
you don't do ass play right what's the
point why it's funny right because like
let's say you get a haircut right so it
looks all presentable it's all the same
length but then back here is just all
bushy and wild it's like or what if you
catch a glimpse like Nadine did the girl
season she's like whoa what's going on
back there it's like I'm not gonna go
back there but I saw it now thinking
about it yeah yeah want to does your
does your bubble hairs come out your
butt cheeks like this it like protrude
is it that if that happens nothing you
are there inside this hair
but luckily there's like it there's
there's no hair like the but I'm like
the weird no a string so you don't have
any hair on your butt I do but it's not
like the one that comes out of the
[ __ ] and I just there's hella hair
wait so you only have hair this is a
long Clint inside that inside the ass
cheeks
he took no no hair on the butt it's like
imagine like the Eye of Sauron
I had like haircut what is that like a
haircut and beard so it's just the the
hole in hair and then nothing so it's
like a sandwich I see you an enemy yeah
like a lion's much time in a deems
[ __ ] yeah I know
Danya he was lying when he called it a
glimpse so I wanted to expose that lives
but know every detail now about false
Tara yeah it looks like this I need to
pay more attention the next time we're
naked yeah wait to him no next time
you're naked no that's not one day can
you pay more attention to deem whatever
you ever-
when we go to we spot the Korean spa
stuff is that ever gonna open again
though oh right I don't know I don't
expose in massages and all that cuz it's
a cesspool of germs yeah well I feel
like damn sure just to like that's a
staple in k-town yeah and I say they
have so many telling no matter what
puberty can go yeah [ __ ] but it's like
straight-up hotboxing corona you go in
there it's in the basement and karana
survive and I don't know if hot boxing
works it's pretty hot like I think some
terms of maybe it's like yeah you're
doing but like you're now but I'll
[ __ ] hottest by that you came you
stand for more than a minute
well I think the germs can survive that
yeah it's in the air and it goes in the
food say no man I don't believe in this
[ __ ] leave in what [ __ ] diseases [ __ ]
but I will wear a mask because I'm
considered other people yeah so even
though in my heart I don't believe this
[ __ ] I'll do it because I am a member of
society you don't believe that it's
really don't believe that it's that
dangerous I'm starting to drop my guard
though with like wearing my mask now
like I'm not as like I gotta wear my
mask all the time and that but when I
see other people to approach me I might
work about to have a conversation
they're wearing a mask and I'm not
wearing a moment oh [ __ ] hold on stay
right there I don't know how comfortable
you are let me look for my masking on
these things and I usually people I
that's okay don't worry about it
yeah my main concern is getting people
with the low immune system like sick
like it'll be my fault that they get
sick or dire even I think that's my main
concern but like me getting sick I'm
like [ __ ] it man I'm immortal right now
I'm just like give it to me my ass I
just beat eczema the other day - you
took only three days and [ __ ] I had a
crazy ass outbreak he beats a man I'll
believe in you get to barter Casey then
because this is gone man I'm looking
Jack thank you see I thought that I
couldn't beat that either but I can beat
that [ __ ] [ __ ] your beat that muscle
wait what are you saying about it we
were trying to move away from what he
was oh really more okay
you say something else about
thoroughness yeah but the mass like I
would rather wear a mask and like if we
find out that it's like fine and we're
good all we do is just wear masks for
like a few months and yeah it's it
wasn't like that big of a deal but it's
like it could prevent and not like it's
not going to kill us we're a mess I love
going on why do you like wearing a mess
I just think it's like pollution is
really cool like it covers nasty smells
and then if people just like have nasty
[ __ ] smells on them
I don't smell it yeah like every time I
travel I always wear much hiking the
other day I went hiking the other day
and like there's this part where at the
climber rope and whatever this is in
Tujunga my old stomping grounds yeah
like ever
that Friendship Park yeah like like dust
was coming flying out our faces and
stuff and luckily we all had masks on
and like that kind of like helped shield
out like the vegetable that's why
they're made for
so Oh true yeah we forget those not just
like construction workers we have to
wear that [ __ ] true I like flying now
like on a airplane with the mask because
I always got like you hydrate it and I
think it's because I fall asleep in my
mouth is open but then pressure air
yeah but then like I've had the mass it
keeps me hydrated yeah people should
have s in the Asian masks they've got it
down to the tea I love you what's Asian
last I just [ __ ] it's not technology
behind it they just use a different how
do they matter making their fly 50
forever yeah the it's like regular
surgical face masks but then they have
Hello Kitty on it hmm that's just purely
aesthetic or is there something
scientifically I think it's powered by
Hello Kitty just making sure Hello Kitty
fights off coronavirus yep yeah but we
don't believe in diseases but if we did
Hello Kitty would right if we did
[Laughter]
[Music]